you auditioned for sound out live and
didn't get the job very true and it's
hard to believe because you've become
you know the biggest thing in show
business so what happened what was your
uh that's not real wood what what
happened in that audition well first of
all I know when you say you can't
believe of course because of my success
now but if you if you hadn't seen this
tape you would understand why I didn't
get it I did an impression of Avery
Johnson okay Wow exactly you see
everybody's face I did an impression of
a person that nobody knew and I remember
explained to Avery Johnson played for
the San Antonio Spurs he was a point
guard and then he wouldn't want to be
the coach of the Dallas Mavericks for
some time and now he's a sports analyst
yeah ok so so instead of doing it as an
impression of a famous famous person
your impression is Avery Johnson
it wasn't it wasn't even a long one this
is exactly what I did was I said ok I'm
gonna do an impression of Avery Johnson
and I remember Lauren Michaels looking
at me and he was like mmhmm okay he
didn't say he didn't know who that was
but I could tell you definitely didn't
know right and I just said I'm passed
the ball to David Robinson
things that listen in on the stack of
Bibles that was my and when I did it
when I did it I stepped back as if it
was great I was like that's it
yeah when you drop the mic yeah in my
mind in my mind I turned around peace
sign
[Applause]
you